the man who fired people on reality tv
and now donald trump is setting up a
reality tv show
to make sure that he won't be fired from
the white house by the american people
this november
each episode during the republican
national convention
features donald trump and members of his
family
it's all called honoring the great
american story
land of heroes land of greatness
join us over the next four nights as we
write the next chapter of our journey
and share our vision as the greatest
country with the greatest citizens
that attain the greatest achievements
so with each day having a theme and
nightly surprises
the donald is looking to trump joe
biden's performance with the democrats
convention
but over the last week the democrats
held the darkest and angriest and
gloomiest
convention in american history it will
be the most boring repetitive dull
mean-spirited convention in history and
of course
we will get a heavy dose of hatred and
rage and cult-like
madness psychosis hysteria against all
things donald trump
this year's convention of the republican
party has been dubbed the people's
convention
and the people have chosen for speakers
at their convention
on the opening night the couple who
pointed their guns at black lives matter
protesters as they walked outside their
mansion now that first
taste of media spotlight has gotten this
couple felony charges
donald trump calls it a disgrace and the
couple
says they're thirsty for more at this
moment in history
if you stand up for yourself and for the
values our country was founded on
the mob spurred on by their allies in
the media
will try to destroy you president trump
will defend the god-given right of every
american
to protect their homes and their
families the themes are coming thick and
fast
tuesday is the land of opportunity
wednesday is the land of heroes
and thursday is the land of greatness
yes
you heard that right that's the night
when donald trump will be accepting the
nomination of the republican party
at the white house surrounded by
supporters
now many people are lapping it up but
not all of them for the same details
for example cnn says that it's pouring
over the details
and that it'll cut away from the reality
tv show if it strays too far
from reality and the television
network's gonna have interesting choices
to make interesting decisions to make
about whether to cut away
if there's this stream of disinformation
happening live
seeing as they did not do this at the
democratic national convention
outrage about cnn's announcement is
certainly not hard to find on the
[Music]
internet
three episodes of this reality tv show
convention
are left no doubt there'll be moments of
pure cringe
drama and high comedy but republicans
are really hoping
that this is a reality tv show that
won't prove to be a turn off
you